>> Greg: OH, LOOK, AFTER BRADY'S
DONE WITH THE NFL, HE WON'T BE
STAYING HOME WITH GISELE.
YEAH, FOX DIDN'T WAIT TO START
BAYING THE QUARTERBACK THAT'S
STILL PLAYING.
TOM BRADY HAS SIGNED A MASSIVE
BROADCASTING DEAL WITH FOX
SPORTS TO ANALYZE NFL GAMES
AFTER HIS RETIREMENT.
THE 10-YEAR CONTRACT IS
REPORTEDLY WORTH $375 MILLION.
NOW HE CAN FINALLY AFFORD TO GET
HIS UGLY FACE FIXED.
[LAUGHTER]
>> Greg: WHAT A HOMELY GUY.
HE'S NO MADISON CAWTHORN.
LET'S BE HONEST.
BRADY QUIETLY CONSIDERED THE
GREATEST QUARTERBACK OF ALL
TIME, ALTHOUGH HE'S NO TRENT
DILFER
DILFER.
>> Tyrus: NO, HE'S NOT.
>> Greg: WILL NOW ALSO BECOME --
TRENT DEL PERFECT.
THE HIGHEST PAID NFL BROADCASTER
OF ALL TIME.
GOOD FOR US, HIRING TOM MIGHT BE
THE BEST DECISION SOMEONE AT FOX
HAS MADE SINCE HIRING YOURS
TRULY
[CHEERS AND APPLAUSE].
>> Greg: THANK YOU, THANK YOU.
OH, STOP, STOP.
WE'RE GOING TO EDIT IT OUT
ANYWAY.
WHICH RAISES THE QUESTION, CAN
TWO TITANS COEXIST AT THE SAME
COMPANY?
ONE OF US IS A LEGENDARY
ATHLETIC SPECIMEN ADORED BY
MILLIONS, AND THE OTHER IS TOM
BRADY.
SAW THAT ONE COMING, DIDN'T YOU?
>> Tyrus: YES, I DID.
>> Greg: YES.
SO LET'S LOOK AT THE FACTS,
SHALL WE?
>> IT'S THE TALE OF THE TAPE
GREG GUTFELD OF TOM BRADY WHO'S
THE MOST SUCCESSFUL GRADUATE OF
THE HIGH SCHOOL IN CALIFORNIA.
GUTFELD FIVE NEW YORK TIMES BEST
SELLERS.
BRADY ONE.
>> GUTFELD THREE WILDLY
SUCCESSFUL TV SHOWS.
BRADY NONE.
GUTFELD NO SUPER BOWL LOSSES.
BREADY THREE SUPER BOWL LOSSES.
GUTFELD PLAYS EIGHT SEASONS OF
YOUTH SOCCER.
BRADY NO DOCUMENTED SOCCER
EXPERIENCE.
GUTFELD IN 2000 WAS EDITOR AND
CHIEF OF SELF MAGAZINE.
BRADY IN 2000 WAS DRAFTED IN THE
SIXTH ROUND.
THE 199TH PICK.
WHAT A LORRIES.
AND FINALLY BRADY IS KNOWN FOR
NOT SHAKING HANDS AFTER A LOSS.
GUTFELD SHAKES HANDS OF ALL
HUMAN BEINGS REGARDLESS OF AGE,
RACE, SEX OR POLITICAL
AFFILIATION.
THIS HAS BEEN THE TALE OF THE
TAPE, GUTFELD VERSUS BRADY.
>> Greg: YES.
KAT, CAN'T WE AGREE THAT I AM
HAPPIER THAN TOM BRADY?
HE MIGHT BE A TAD BETTER LOOKING
AND SLIGHTLY BETTER IN SPORTS
BUT I AM HAPPY YOU KNOW ME AS A
HAPPY PERSON.
I CANNOT GET ANY HAPPIER
>> Kat: I WOULD NEVER SAY THAT
ABOUT YOU.
>> Tyrus: YEAH, HAVE YOU EVER
GOTTEN A HAPPY --
>> Kat: YEAH, JUST WANT TO MAKE
SURE YOU HAVE A GREAT DAY.
>> Tyrus: NO.
HE'S LIKE YOU WON'T BELIEVE
THIS.
>> Greg: REALLY?
>> Tyrus: I AM WRITING TO INFORM
YOU THAT THAT BEHAVIOR WILL NOT
BE TOLERATED
>> Kat: YEAH.
>> Tyrus: YOU'VE RUINED MY DAY.
>> Greg: YOU KNOW --.
>> Tyrus: YEAH, RIGHT?
>> Kat: I KNEW I SHOULD HAVE
BEEN AN NFL QUARTERBACK.
>> Greg: YOU COULDN'T PICK UP A
FOOTBALL
>> Kat: I COULD.
IF I USED TWO HANDS I COULD.
>> Greg: BUT YOU CAN'T THROW A
FOOTBALL WITH TWO HANDS.
TYRUS, HIM AND I BOTH WENT TO
THE SAME HIGH SCHOOL I HAVE TO
BRING THAT UP ALL THE TIME.
>> Tyrus: YOU CONSTANTLY DO.
>> Greg: AND I'M TIRED OF THE
FACT THEY NAMED A FIELD AFTER
HIM WHEN MY NAME IS GUTFELD.
THEY COULD CALL IT GUTFELD
FIELD.
>> Tyrus: MAYBE YOU'LL GET THE
LIBRARY BECAUSE YOU WRITE BOOKS.
>> Greg: I DON'T THINK SO.
THE LIBRARY AT SARAH HIGH SCHOOL
WAS NOT CLEAN.
IT WAS A VERY DIRTY
DISGUSTING --.
>> Tyrus: HOW WOULD YOU KNOW?
BIG REASON WHY PROBABLY.
>> Kat: MAKE SURE OF IT.
>> Tyrus: THIS MIGHT WORK OUT IN
YOUR FAVOR.
HISTORICALLY WHEN THE GREAT GO
TO BROADCASTING IT DOESN'T WORK
OUT VERY WELL.
JORDAN, MUHAMMAD ALI, THEY
PLAYED THE GAME AT SUCH A HIGH
LEVEL WHEN THEY TALK ABOUT IT
THEY COME ACROSS AS
CONDESCENDING.
>> Greg: BECAUSE THERE'S NO ONE
BETTER THAN THEY ARE.
>> Tyrus: AND WHEN THEY WATCH
GUYS PLAY IT'S SUPER CRITICAL.
SO THIS MIGHT NOT BE I HATE TO
SAY IT BUT THIS COULD BE THE
BEST THING THAT EVER HAPPENED TO
YOU.
>> Greg: FANTASTIC.
>> Tyrus: HE'S GOING TO COME TO
YOU FOR HELP.
>> Greg: AND I WON'T BE THERE
BECAUSE WHERE WAS HE WHEN I
NEEDED HELP ARI?
WHERE?
ANSWER ME PRESS SECRETARY.
>> Ari: WHO GRADUATED FIRST, YOU
OR HIM.
>> Greg: I KNOW WE LOOK SO CLOSE
IN AGE BUT I DID GRADUATE FIRST.
>> Ari: JUST A LITTLE.
>> Greg: 1980 -- WHAT WAS IT?
'87.
>> Tyrus: YOU GRADUATED EARLY
THOUGH, TOO, CORRECT?
>> Greg: YEAH, I WAS LIKE
DOOGIE HOWSER.
I WENT TO MED SCHOOL AT 14.
>> Ari: I AM A MIAMI DOLPHIN FAN
I AM CHEERING FOR BRADY TO FAIL.
LIKE 15 YEARS IN A ROW EVERY
SUNDAY WHICH HE NEVER DID, BUT
I'M HOPING HE FAILED.
>> Greg: I'M HOPING HE DOES WELL
BECAUSE I'M MAGNANIMOUS DAY
BEGUN.
MAGNANIMOUS.
I NEVER SAID THAT WORD OUT
CLOUT.
>> Dagen: WITH THIS CONTRACT I
KNOW WHY SNACKS ARE LOOKING A
LITTLE THIN, YOU KNOW?
WHERE'S MY CHET MIX.
THEY'RE CUTTING CORNERS ALREADY.
>> Greg: $40 MILLION A YEAR,
THAT'S LIKE TWICE WHAT I MAKE.
[LAUGHTER].
>> Tyrus: WAIT.
SAY WHAT?
>> Greg: THEY HAVE TO CUT
CORNERS SOMEWHERE, THEY JUST
REMOVED THE ENTIRE OUTNUMBERED
SHOW.
THEY JUST DISSOLVED IT
>> Kat: NO, THEY JUST REMOVED
THE COUCH.
>> Tyrus: EVERYBODY'S SITTING ON
THE FLOOR
>> Kat: NOW THERE'S A BLANKET,
BLANKETS ON THE FLOOR.
>> Tyrus: OUTNUMBERED
SLEEP-OVER.
>> Greg:.
>> Greg: YES.
GREAT IDEA.
>> Dagen: I'LL ADD ONE THING
THOUGH, TOM BRADY'S PROBABLY
THINKING TV'S REALLY EASY AND
IT'S SUPER HARD.
KAT WENT THROUGH ALL THE
NECESSARY GROOMING.
EVEN FOR MEN, LIKE IF YOU DON'T
BLINK YOU LOOK LIKE A PSYCHOPATH
AND IF YOU BLINK TOO MUCH YOU
LOOK LIKE A PSYCHOPATH SO YOU
HAVE TO LOOK FOR THE HAPPY
MEDIUM AND I'VE JET TO FIND IT
IN 20 YEARS.
>> Greg: WELL, YOU KNOW WHAT?
I'M HAPPY AND I'M A MEDIUM.
AT LEAST THAT'S A GUESS.
>> Tyrus: VERY MAGNANIMOUS OF
YOU.
>> Greg: THANK YOU.
>> Tyrus: EXTREME MAGA.
>>